- Let's go get this money!
(upbeat music)
- [Host] You might know
the social media app TikTok
for its viral dance videos
or as the distinctly
modern springboard to fame.
- [Tokker] Here's a tax
loophole that actually works.
- [Host] But recently, it's
also become a popular platform
for Millennials and Gen Zers
to put their entrepreneurial
spirit into action.
- You probably won't believe
this really weird side hustle.
- [Host] Whether it's
pitching a side hustle,
- [Entrepreneur] So
basically, long story short,
I resold gently used clothing.
- [Host] Bragging about an ecom business,
- I've made over $1 million on Shopify
and this is how I started.
- [Host] Or documenting
a real estate investment,
- [Investor] I bought an
entire mobile home park
about a year and a half ago.
- [Host] This TikTok subculture
is all about making money.
- A super easy way to make money at home.
- [Host] Or at least teaching
you how you can, too.
- Here's how to buy your
first house using no bank,
no cash and no credit.
- [Host] Search the hashtag
side hustle or entrepreneur
on TikTok and you'll find yourself
in a vast sea of self help.
- [Jay] How to make $200 per hour
just by removing background images.
- [Host] New entrepreneurs
are getting into everything
from affiliate marketing, investing...
- Let's do a refresher
on what a dividend is.
- [Host] No matter the business
model, you can probably find
someone on TikTok who is doing it.
- You will not believe the
profit of this home flip.
- [Host] According to TikTok,
#entrepreneur has accrued more
than 7.2 billion views.
While #sidehustle has more
than 4.7 billion views.
- This is the business side of TikTok.
- [Host] So can this corner
of one of the world's most
popular social media apps
actually make you a
successful entrepreneur?
- This is a community of mostly
young people coming together
and saying, how do we make some money?
- [Host] Nader Alizadeh
is the CEO of Linquia,
a marketing firm that
specializes in connecting brands
with social media influencers.
- I think if you're a young
person trying to get a job today
versus 12 months ago, it
is significantly harder.
There's no more opportune
time to be involved in trying
to come up with a side hustle than now.
- [Interviewer] What
do you do for a living?
- What do I do for a living?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, what do you do?
- I'm a dropshipper.
- [Host] One popular TikTok
hustle is dropshipping.
- Good morning.
- That's how 24-year-old
Austin Rabin says he makes
between 30 and $40,000 in profit a month
selling consumer goods.
- I wanted to start just to provide tips
in the ecommerce community
because I know when I was starting out,
I didn't really have any go-to
channel or source that I used
to answer my questions.
- [Host] Dropshipping is a business model
that allows online retailers
to sell products to their customers
without ever really stocking
the items themselves.
Instead, when a customer
visits a dropshipper's store,
they're purchasing the
item from a third party
that ships it directly to the customer.
- From there, you'll
typically run advertisements
to get traffic onto your store.
There's a couple different ways.
One would be Facebook advertisements,
which includes Instagram.
That's really the main
source for dropshippers.
This right here is
probably the number one...
- [Host] Austin started
using TikTok in August.
Since then, he has built his channel
to more than 766,000 likes and
more than 82,000 followers.
Two of his videos have gotten
more than 1 million views.
- There's so much organic
reach on TikTok, just the way
that the whole platform works is insane.
I think that's why a lot
of people are attracted
to the platform because you can
essentially become some sort
of internet sensation overnight.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] The two primary ways
people make money on TikTok
are through its Creator Marketplace,
which connects TikTokkers with brands.
In its Creator Fund, a
$1 billion pot of money
TikTok is using to pay
its most popular creators
for their views,
but most TikTokkers can't
make a living just off TikTok.
That's because brands
gravitate to the top creators
with the biggest followings.
And even if their videos rack up tens
or hundreds of thousands of views,
users report low or inconsistent payouts.
To date, TikTok has not explained
exactly how it calculates
payouts from the Creator Fund.
Rabin said 95% of his income
comes from dropshipping.
But thanks to his growing
TikTok audience, he has managed
to start a variety of small side hustles.
- Link is in my TikTok bio.
- [Host] In his TikTok
bio, Rabin provides links
to a variety of promotions,
pre-built dropshipping websites
and access to private consultant services
for those who want to learn how to sell.
- I wanna buy this house for $500,000
and the bank offered me a
15-year or a 30-year mortgage.
- [Host] That potential to
quickly build a large audience
is also what attracted
another TikTok entrepreneur,
Humphrey Yang to the platform.
Yang specializes in sharing
practical personal finance advice.
- At the end of 2019, I made
a decision to make 30 days
of TikToks in a row, but
by the end of the 30 days,
I had over 120,000 followers
and I just never looked back.
- [Host] Today, Yang's TikTok channel
has 1.1 million followers
and 15.7 million likes.
But he said those numbers aren't enough
to make a living off the platform.
Although he occasionally
does some sponsored posts
on TikTok, Yang said
he sees the app as more
of a marketing tool than a revenue stream.
- I do view TikTok as more
of an audience builder,
awareness, top of funnel.
So basically anybody that
sees me for the first time,
they might see me first on
TikTok and then they might get
into my other social
channels, YouTube for example
or Instagram where they
can learn a little bit more
about finance if they wish.
- [Host] Since it launched
in September 2016,
TikTok has seen breakneck
growth, being downloaded
over 2 billion times on the
App Store and Google Play.
Today, it's one of the
web's most downloaded apps
on par with other social
media giants like WhatsApp,
Instagram and Facebook.
TikTok has more than 50
million daily US users
or roughly 15% of the US population.
- Building a business
that wasn't even mine.
- [Host] But the benefits
of getting on TikTok
aren't just the potential
to grow a large audience.
- It's been fantastic for me networking.
So that community that we're talking about
in that specific hashtag,
I've connected with a lot
of those big guys on there
that have similar followings
or bigger followings than
me and they offered me tips
just on the side in a private messages.
- I will frequently receive
messages from people saying
that because they watched my videos,
they've decided to take
more responsibility
in their own personal financial life.
And those are quite
fulfilling to actually see
that my videos are spurring action.
- Being an influencer
is not for everybody.
This is about independent
of the number of followers
that you have, how can
you go out and make money?
- [Tokker] $5, $10, $20.
- So here's a side hustle
that nobody talks about.